right summer is here and registered
dietitian meeson
shares essentials to make this summer
your healthiest yet
including 5-minute meals blender-free
smoothies and an easy way to upgrade
the nutrition of your backyard barbecue
hey las vegas now summer is here and i
have the healthy essentials you need to
kick off the season
starting with a nutritious breakfast
that will help you stay cool
these eve blender free plant-based
smoothies can be made in three steps
simply run the wheel under water for a
few seconds pop the cubes in a mason jar
cover the cubes with almond milk let it
melt for 20 minutes
and shake each smoothie is made with
organic fruits and vegetables
plant-based protein which adds staying
power and nutrient-dense ingredients
like chia seeds and hemp seeds
plus they have no added sugar you can
order them frozen shipped to your door
with free shipping at evennutrition.com
next i have a five minute customizable
lunch you'll enjoy
all summer long build a satisfying lunch
with protein fiber and good fats with
this five minute wrap hack for my
mediterranean hummus wrap start by
cutting a line from the center of the
tortilla to the bottom
next add hummus to the first quadrant
this fresh cravings hummus comes in
classic
and roasted red pepper is super creamy
and made with a short list of high
quality ingredients
add romaine and red onion to the second
quadrant chicken and feta to the third
quadrant
and sundred tomatoes and olives to the
fourth fold it up to the side
and down and enjoy chicken adds protein
and veggies add filling fiber
while this hummus offers a balanced mix
of good fats fiber and protein from
chilean extra virgin olive oil
non-gmo chickpeas and savory tahini you
can find it at
smith's in the produce department for
this taco wrap add fresh cravings salsa
which you can find in the produce
section at smithson walmart
spinach ground meat and cheese fold it
up the same way and enjoy
as you grill out this summer try my
veggie bun sliders
veggie buns lower the calories and
carbohydrates and increase the vitamins
minerals and fiber i started with the
primal kitchen condiments including the
unsweetened ketchup
award-winning buffalo sauce and famous
avocado oil mayo besides loading up on
veggies at your grill out focus on using
condiments that are made with high
quality ingredients
and free of added sugar or artificial
ingredients like these by primal kitchen
made with avocado oil and savory spices
find them on amazon and most major
grocery stores my last summer essentials
will help you stay calm and relaxed
all season long keep zao ashwagandha on
hand which is an ancient indian herb
that may help the body manage stress
or make your own calming spa wellness
water with cherry flavored zao
calm now formulated with ashwagandha and
other herbs with potential calming
effects like lemon balm
and hawthorne berry find both at walmart
and soundnutrition.com
research also suggests that certain
foods may help promote feelings of calm
like nuts seeds and whole grains rich in
magnesium
and mackerel and pasture-raised eggs
sources of omega-3
fats i hope you enjoyed these recipes
and tips you can find them at my website
nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share meal ideas
and nutrition tips daily